عندما اكتشفنا هذا الكهف ، علمنا
أنه سيكون عميقًا
[موسيقى]
ها نحن عند مدخل متغير دلتا
في رحلة الاتصال
اليوم رطبة جدًا ولكننا
نذهب نستخدم تقنيات المسح بالليزر حتى نتمكن من
بناء 3D  نموذج للكهف أثناء
نزولنا ، لذا لدينا فكرة جيدة جدًا
عن مدى عمقها بالضبط وفي
هذه الحالة علمنا أن هذا الكهف
سوف يتصل بـ Negley عند المستوى الأساسي ، حيث
كان أعمق كهف في أستراليا
سابقًا 397 مترًا  عميق
وعرفنا أنه بغض النظر عن ما سيكون هذا الكهف
أعمق أربعة أمتار بناءً
على الموقع الذي هو عميق جدًا بالنسبة
لأستراليا ولكن هناك كهوف أعمق بكثير
في العالم عندما يفكر معظم الناس
في الكهوف التي يفكرون فيها حقًا صغيرة
ضيقة ومروعة  المساحات التي تكون خانقة بعض الشيء
وسأعترف بوجود
القليل من ذلك في هذا الكهف حيث توجد
حرفيًا على اليدين والركبتين عبر
نفق وسحب حقيبة خلفنا ولكن
هناك أيضًا مساحات شاسعة توجد بها مساحات
كبيرة مثل ca  في
هذا الكهف المعين في كثير من الأحيان ،
نحن بجوار شلال ، لذا فإن الظروف
ليست ممتعة للغاية في الواقع
لأنها صاخبة حقًا إذا كنت تستطيع تخيل كيف
يبدو الوقوف بجانب شلال في
مكان مغلق حيث كل شيء
يتردد ، تسمع فقط هذا الضخم
هدير الماء الذي يجعل من الصعب حقًا
التواصل مع أعضاء الفريق الآخرين ، ما
الذي
يسعدنا أن نطلق عليه متغير دلتا
لأننا وجدنا أنه في يناير من هذا العام
تمكنا من استخدام
موضوع التسمية السرية بالكامل للكهف بأكمله ، على
سبيل المثال هناك  قسم غامض حقًا
من Passage والذي ينطلق في
كل مكان ، لذلك أطلقنا عليه اسم
الموزع الفائق ، لقد قمنا بالاتصال الذي وصلنا
إلى الجزء السفلي من متغير دلتا ،
ولا يزال لدينا الكثير من الأعمال غير المكتملة
مع متغير دلتا ، ولدينا
عدد قليل جدًا من الممرات الجانبية التي
ما زلنا بحاجة إلى رسم خريطة واستكشاف